so many dating app users have wondered
is my bio
interesting enough does my profile photo
stand out
why can't i find a date on this thing is
it me or is it the way i
am using the app it is so overwhelming
sometimes and today we're cutting
through the confusion and telling you
exactly what you need to do because we
enlisted the help of
relationship and dating coach demona
hoffman
and we teamed her up with brooke a
flight attendant from nashville
tennessee
who says she is tired of swiping without
having any luck
well demona friend of the show she is
here let's take a look
hey damona i'm so happy that you are
able to meet with me today
wonderful to meet you i'm brooke smith
i'm 30 years old
i am a flight attendant for the last i
just started my seventh year
i want to know how i can get the most
out of maximizing
my dating app experience to get those
better matches
when i read your profile it reads a
little bit to me more like an
instagram feed than a
profile i like to have my clients use
the 3cs the 3cs are color context and
character
color is really important in that first
photo particularly
the color red is very attractive to men
so you have red lipstick which is
beautiful you have a red rose
and you look very fun and inviting and
you're smiling there
i want to get rid of the photos that
show more
of the destinations that you're at and
really focus more on the context
and then the character showing your
personality which i think your
your chicken nuggets photo certainly
does
i think that you achieve what you're
going for when you say she's super fun
and a little nerdy queso solves all her
problems we just have to fill in those
other photos
to show more of the context and make you
the star of your profile
you've got all the best advice you have
so much going for you girl demona
i am going to take your advice and i'm
going to get right to work on my dating
app
right now and i will see you next week
with hopefully a date
maybe two wearing the color
red is a roaring oh okay let's welcome
brooke smith and damona hoffman
hi demona hi
drew good to see you again so demona
how are some of the common mistakes
spotted on brook's profile something
that you think you can solve
well we can solve any dating problem in
any dating app
issue since the last time i saw you drew
i actually became
the official dating coach of okcupid and
so i see these profile problems a lot
but they are completely fixable what i
can tell you
is that okay cupid users who complete
their profile
see 200 percent more matches and you
know what more matches mean
they mean more dates so with a couple of
little fix we can make a big difference
for brooke
brooke how do you feel um when i was
talking to damona i was like gosh
she's really understanding like what
what the issue is with me in dating apps
and so i'm i'm
really excited to to get right into it
start swiping
find my mr right all right let's do it
okay brooke you are gonna go live with
your new
profile right now on your dating app and
all show long
we're going to be checking in with you
to see if you've had any success i mean
do you think we can hit that in the one
hour demona
oh yeah especially with this great
profile that brooke now has i'm feeling
really confident about her
opportunities brooke how's it going any
any matches anything i actually you have
one match drew i'm pretty excited
his name's cole he's 6'3 lives in new
york city
so i'm pretty pretty pumped don't know
what to do now
so need your help uh actually i think
you want to be asking demona because i
actually feel like i have the same
question
you get hit demona and i think a lot of
us women
want to go oh it's the man who's
supposed to make the first move
what do we do in this moment oh no no no
drew
you cannot treat dating apps the same
way you treated
online offline irl dating right it's a
completely different media
so i've said for the longest time that
women should take control of their
dating destiny you should
be the one doing the choosing not
waiting to get
chose and now the data really backs this
up that women who take initiative
really do have far more matches and more
matches mean more messages and more
messages mean what
more dates okay all right so
i think i'm gonna go for it all right
thank you to my girl yes
brooke drew
hi brooke hi jamoney thank you
um i want good news i want good news
what's the status
okay all right drew so i meshed with
cole
and his bio had said something like i
was crushing my goals all quarantined
and now i'm ready to crush some hearts
so i messaged him and i just said um
please don't crush my heart but you can
surely try to win it over
and then from there i know right i
was proud of myself on that one but
right in from there um he
immediately asked me about my favorite
tv show big brother i told him i eat
sleep breathe julie chen all summer
and i'm looking for a plus one to expect
the unexpected all summer with me
and he was totally in um and now we've
just had some witty banner back and
forth
and things are going really good okay i
love this i love how you took demona's
advice i love your quippy comeback
it's adorable i'm glad he bit it doesn't
surprise me
now demona how should brooke proceed
from here
she's got him on the hook things are
going well
but where do we go from here and frankly
how do we not screw it up
what now well first of all you can't
screw it up if it's the right person
it's going to work out so just
move forward forward with that
confidence brook but we're off to a
strong start
what i don't want you to do though is
get stuck in the texting trap
you know that cycle when you're just
sending messages back and forth and back
and forth and you're like hey is anybody
going to make a move here
you want to move things to the next
phase which can be
a phone call i love the phone call and
then you can really get a sense of
who he is and whether you want to move
offline and then
you got to get on to that date you can't
really
tell who somebody is or effectively
filter through your dates
on on messaging or on text
you have to actually meet face to face
and see if you really like each other
i'm super excited super excited he seems
to
literally feed off my energy which is
pretty hard to do sometimes with me so i
love it i'm so excited
great i love this and demona you are
so smart when it comes to this stuff
thank gosh you're leaving the charge
you're so wise so thank you demona
hoffman
thank you brooke smith we can't wait to
find out what happens next
i love this to all of you who are
watching at home i hope you appreciated
demona's wisdom
i know i get so much out of it and thank
you for spending your time with us today
we know you could spend it anywhere
thanks for choosing to hang out here we
hope to see you soon
you